clark county administrator rob tell us
is behind bars tonight accused of
killing local journalist jeff german
good evening to you i'm brian loftis and
i'm denise valdez all of this unfolding
today on spanish stepp's lane which is
right in the piccoli ranch community off
of charleston and wallapie we have team
coverage tonight our eight news now
investigators will look at the turmoil
that helps spark what exactly happened
but first sasha loftis joining us live
from that neighborhood with more on what
happened today sasha
brian and denise this neighborhood is
quiet now but it was an explosive scene
earlier with metro police and tactical
teams swarming telus's home behind me
those who live in this area say it was
all unsettling to say the least
a west valley neighborhood taken over
wednesday
as metro police and tactical teams
descended on the home of clark county
administrator robert tellis and arrested
him in connection with the murder of
investigative journalist jeff gearman am
i concerned
the hours-long ordeal left many living
nearby on edge as neighbors had officers
on their street all day and were
eventually evacuated from their homes
i
took an interest in this because their
exits were blocked off you wake up in
the morning and you see the police tape
attached to your tree in your front yard
you're thinking what's going on out here
sources tell the 8 news now
investigators telus was taken to umc
after hurting himself and was later
booked into the clark county detention
center to think it actually might have
happened isn't wild investigators
released a photo of an suv related to
the crime which sources tell the 8 news
now investigators matched one of the
county officials cars it's not something
you see normally it's something you hear
like a true crime series or like a movie
while those here can't begin to know the
ins and outs of what happened
they say it's surprising in what's
normally such a quiet neighborhood it's
crazy
now sources also tell the eight news now
investigators that dna linked him to
this crime there was also a bag with
bloody clothes found inside telus home
according to those sources now he is due
in court tomorrow morning he is booked
on an open murder charge of the clark
county detention detention center he
will face a judge tomorrow at 1 30 in
the afternoon reporting live tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now